[Música]
si observáis esta manzana
podréis saber que es de color verde
que tiene una forma imperfecta mente
esférica
qué es un alimento
todos conocemos lo que es una manzana no
pero si hubiera más de esta manzana de
lo que se puede observar a simple vista
y si hubiera más de la manzana de lo que
podemos percibir con nuestros cinco
sentidos
acaso no les da curiosidad
para mí la curiosidad de poder ver más
allá es algo que me ha movido desde que
soy pequeño me acuerdo perfectamente del
momento en el que mi profesora de
ciencias en clase de primaria nos estaba
explicando lo que era el planeta tierra
y nos enseñó una fotografía del
mapamundi a lo que yo me quedé
impresionado de lo pequeño que era el
mundo y lo dije dije que pequeño que es
el planeta generando también entonces su
asombro
poco después mi hermano mayor me regaló
un libro que trataba sobre el sistema
solar entonces claro hay cambio la cosa
imagínense
los sorprendido que me quedé al ver esto
no recuerdo exactamente lo que dije pero
seguramente pensaría algo como es
inmenso
y ahí empecé a desarrollar una
curiosidad por el cosmos y por el
espacio y por conocer todo lo que no
podía ver con mis ojos en el planeta en
el que habitaba
tanta fue mi curiosidad por explorar
todo ese conocimiento que continúe
haciéndolo de forma autodidacta hasta
que lo resume todo en una cartulina y se
lo presenté a mi clase para que todos
pudieran
entender y pudieran también compartir
conmigo esa ilusión por el espacio
acaso no es
la curiosidad algo que nos une a todos
los humanos por igual
qué habría pasado si en el momento en el
que nosotros fuimos seres recolectores
no hubiéramos tenido la curiosidad por
querer probar todos los alimentos todos
los materiales que formaban parte de
nuestra realidad de nuestro alrededor
que habría sucedido si nosotros no
hubiéramos puesto la mano en el fuego al
ver un tronco arder y nos hubiéramos
quemado aprendiendo así que podíamos
cocinar los alimentos
o si no hubiéramos tenido la curiosidad
por querer explorar el planeta
quiénes seríamos ahora qué habría
sucedido con los humanos y dónde
estaríamos
la curiosidad por lo tanto es un
fenómeno que forma parte de la
naturaleza nata de nosotros como humanos
y que también permite entonces la
evolución
entonces cómo se puede unir la
curiosidad con el momento actual que
estamos viviendo en el que hay un
crecimiento tan rápido de la tecnología
todos usamos la tecnología de forma
diaria para comunicarnos para realizar
tareas del hogar cualquier tipo de tarea
puede ser hecha por un dispositivo
tecnológico y nosotros solemos usar la
tecnología de dos formas distintas
en la primera figura pueden ver un
dispositivo un dispositivo tecnológico
que está emitiendo
información de dentro hacia afuera puede
ser un mensaje puede ser la reproducción
de cualquier tipo de media está
reproduciendo algo está emitiendo
información de acuerdo de dentro hacia
afuera como he dicho antes en la figura
2 observamos totalmente lo contrario
nosotros tenemos un dispositivo
tecnológico y estamos recibiendo
información estamos recibiendo mensajes
estamos recibiendo cualquier tipo de
media e incluso estamos capturando la
realidad que nos rodea si nosotros
tenemos un dispositivo y sacamos una
foto que estamos haciendo estamos
capturando el reflejo de la luz sobre
las superficies que nos rodean estamos
capturando la realidad en cierta manera
no solo generando un recuerdo que luego
podemos guardar
qué sucede si nosotros cogemos un
dispositivo tecnológico y cuando
recibimos esta información que captura
la realidad añadimos un paso más a la
cadena añadimos una emisión
y qué sucedería si al final de esta
cadena hubiera un ser humano
lo que sucede es que estamos revelando
la realidad a través de los sentidos
revelar la realidad se conoce como saber
mucho más allá de lo que nos rodea de
explorar la realidad que podemos
observar pero no sabemos todo lo que hay
a nuestro alrededor realmente nos
perdemos mucho por la limitación de los
cinco sentidos de los que disponemos al
ser humanos
las personas que revelan la realidad a
través de dispositivos tecnológicos se
conocen como cyborgs son personas que
usan la tecnología para saber qué hay
más allá para continuar con la
curiosidad que nos hace ser humanos pero
de una forma completamente nueva es un
punto de cambio en esta evolución
hay diferentes personas que ya están
trabajando con la realidad revelada a
través de los dispositivos y como pueden
observar aquí les presento a tres de
ellos en primer lugar observamos una
fotografía de neil harbisson el creador
de la ciber foundation y quien creó un
dispositivo en forma de antena llamado
sentido tono cromático para poder
escuchar los colores que él no ve por
una condición en la que ve en blanco y
negro condición médica
entonces se le está revelando la
realidad del color porque de otra forma
no lo puede percibir a la derecha vemos
una fotografía de mon rivas quien se
implantó dos chips en sus pies para
poder sentir de forma constante en forma
de vibración los movimientos sísmicos de
la tierra para sentirse más conectada
con el planeta que habitan y también
para revelar como os he dicho antes una
parte de realidad que de otra forma no
podría saber que existe
a su derecha vemos una foto de manuel de
aguas quien también dispone de un
sentido llamamos sentido a estos
dispositivos cyborg y su sentido sirve
para revelarle la realidad atmosférica
todo el rato está sintiendo los cambios
en la presión y de esta manera puede
avanzarse a los cambios meteorológicos
de la zona en la que esté en este
momento hay muchas formas distintas de
revelar la realidad es una gama casi
infinita pues hay mucho que nos estamos
perdiendo
en mi caso he creado un sentido que
podéis observar en mi espalda llamado
cosmic sense o sentido cósmico y que va
completamente ligado a la curiosidad que
yo sentía de pequeño con explorar el
espacio
llega a un punto en el que me di cuenta
en el que no podía ir al espacio de
forma física como es obvio entonces tuve
que crear un dispositivo para poder
hacer el espacio venir a mí en este caso
lo que me permite el cosmic sense es
escuchar las melodías del cosmos más
concretamente las melodías de los rayos
cósmicos y se preguntarán qué son los
rayos cósmicos
los rayos cósmicos son partículas que
salen disparadas de los agujeros negros
y también de las supernovas y viajan por
el espacio casi a la velocidad de la luz
hasta que chocan con un planeta o con un
asteroide
ahora mismo entre ustedes y yo hay una
lluvia inmensa de rayos cósmicos que no
existe si no podemos percibir pero que
está presente de todas formas
cada vez que un rayo cósmico toca la
atmósfera del planeta se genera una
lluvia de partículas subatómicas y el
70% de estas partículas se llaman mont
es una partícula que únicamente existe
cuando este fenómeno sucede mi sentido
recibe estas partículas cuando caen
encima y las traduce a una nota musical
correspondiente dependiendo de lo rápido
o lo lento que vayan por tanto
haciéndolo más claro una nota más aguda
significa que hay un rayo cósmico que
proviene de más cerca del planeta y una
nota más grave significa que hay un rayo
cósmico que proviene de más lejos
viniendo incluso de otra galaxia
gracias a este sentido estoy pudiendo
revelar la realidad que me rodea y lo
estoy pudiendo traducir a arte
esta es una partitura de rayos cósmicos
así es como suena el espacio
tiene una melodía completamente
distinta a la que estamos acostumbrados
porque estamos acostumbrados a una
armonía creada por los humanos pero
claro el espacio no entiende de ningún
tipo de creación humana es completamente
aleatoria
pero eso también la hace muy interesante
[Música]
así es como son al espacio y esto es lo
que yo estoy de forma constante cuando
uso mis sentidos cyborg escuchando
estoy pudiendo revelar la realidad del
espacio
en el futuro todos seremos cyborg
porque una cualidad tan nata del humano
como es la curiosidad ligada a un
crecimiento exponencial tan grande como
el de la tecnología va a ser que
queramos continuar explorando la tierra
esta descubierta de forma física pero
hay mucho más que nos estamos perdiendo
no conocemos todo lo que nos rodea por
el simple hecho de poder verlo o de
poder evitarlo cada persona va a poder
crear su sentido va a poder generar una
percepción individual
dependiendo de sus necesidades y eso
también es lo que va a hacer que sea tan
interesante el movimiento cyborg que en
el futuro
ahora observe en esta manzana
si lo observan podrán ver que es de
color verde
que tiene una forma imperfecta mente
esférica
qué es un alimento
todos conocemos lo que es una manzana no
aquí veis una fotografía de una manzana
cuando se encuentra bajo un campo
eléctrico
imagínense entonces
si de esta manzana hay tanto que nos
estamos perdiendo
cuanto hay que nos estamos perdiendo de
un universo infinito al no revelar la
realidad
cuanto estamos perdiendo nos al no
disponer de un dispositivo que nos está
ayudando a continuar explorando pues al
fin y al cabo nosotros somos seres
curiosos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]